thanks so much for coming to this video
my name is Samuel Leeds and I'm a
property investor and I love to put out
videos and content helping other people
to become successful in property so this
week Q&A Sunday I'm gonna be taking the
most common and burning questions that
have come up on YouTube under the Q&A
comment section and I'm gonna be
answering some of those questions so if
you've got questions specifically for me
that you'd like me to answer then my
suggestions to comment them below in the
comment section and I'll do my absolute
best to answer them next week on Sundays
Q&A session so anything at all if it's
an igloo property question or if as I'm
speaking and I'm answering questions if
you get like an offshoot of the question
just comment your thoughts and questions
below also the more comments questions
it helps the YouTube algorithm so make
sure you do comment something even if
it's just your favorite color so what do
we got
okay some great questions from last week
so Tracy cone further says I'm just
wondering what kind of check should do
for prospective tenants to make sure you
get the decent kind who will pay on time
etc yeah I mean the things that tenants
need to do is just pay on time look
after the house
that's it however there's lots of
different types of checks you can get I
would suggest getting a good property
management company and I think probably
the most important check on a tenant I
mean there's of course this there's
referencing work checks as credit checks
but I think the most important if you
want them to be a good tenant is to ask
their previous landlord so don't ask
their current landlord because their
current landlord might hate them but
doesn't want to say that because then
they'll never get rid of them because
they'll never past them referencing so
go to the previous landlord and that's
probably the most powerful thing you can
do and just do it affordability check as
well check that they can afford the
round they're owning decent see their
finances and their pay slips and just
make sure you get a deposit off them and
any other checks that the property
management company thinks you need to
get oh I would do so really important
don't take a tenant because you're
desperate for returns moving fast if
you're not comfortable overthinking or
if they don't if they don't pass the
checks
don't move min queen of success hey I
know you you were at the crash course
just last week so thanks for commenting
on YouTube I'm the mom of three and we
get started but I'll be doing it alone
as I'm in the middle of a divorce sorry
to hear that
I notice how many people do it with
their partners is it possible to do it
alone yeah it is possible to do alone
for sure I think it's it's it's easier
if you're doing it with a partner but if
you haven't got a partner or if you've
got a partner who's not supportive or if
you go through a divorce like you are
what I would say queen of success is
firstly you're going to be successful
because you're called the queen of
success but just make sure you've got
people around you friends you know find
friends that are successful in property
people that are on the same kind of
journey issue and even if you're buying
the property in your own name and you're
doing it as an individual instead of a
partnership having success buddies is
really really important so wish you all
the best I know you'll be successful as
well because you came to the crash
course last week so congrats for coming
and let me know how you get on me you
deals what else have we got
Jay Rowley what do you reckon is the
best way into property if your time
short and work nights do you recommend
starting a limited company when doing a
joint venture and you are the hands-off
partner just putting in the money okay
if your hands off time short and put it
in all the money you've got to be dead
careful because there'll be people that
will rip you off so Jay get educated
because if you if your time short and
and you've got money and you'll just
write in the checks out or funding in
someone else's doing all the work
nothing wrong with that but you'd make
you need to make sure that I don't pull
the wool over your eyes so just make
sure that you're working with people
that you can really trust people have
got experienced people cuz they can back
that up make sure that the the company
is all or the agreement is drawn up by a
solicitor as well so that you've got a
trusted third party coming in and
checking all the processes so do you
recommend starting a limited company for
sure also when you think the joint
venture with someone you don't have to
say hey let's start a company and agree
that all our probably deals will be
through this company you can set up a
company you can just buy one house so
what I would do is I'd say look let's do
a joint-venture not let's be joint
venture partners forever and ever
let's do a joint venture let's see how
it goes if it goes well then we can
maybe buy another house in the same
company so just kind of do it slowly
slowly maybe start on a small deal but
my best advice but yeah for sure go set
up a company just make sure you've got
the good professional people around you
make sure it's done properly especially
if you're putting in the money and make
sure you know what you're doing you've
got other people around you or you've
got some education yourself and how do
you get the education I mean for the
stuff you're talking about you might not
even need masses of property knowledge
you might just need a good education
around joint ventures and the law and
accounts which you might be able to get
from just paying dishonest or an
accountant hands-on so yeah that'll be
my advice Pablo Ramirez how to transfer
a personal portfolio being hit hard by
article 24 to a limited company I have
four properties in my name thanks Sam
you're beautiful beautiful so good luck
with around the school and water
projects thank you so much is actually
Uganda but really appreciate that sorry
to hear that you've been hit hard by the
article 24 sexuality is actually called
section 24 the tax changes okay
unfortunately transferring properties
from an individual name to a limited
company name is difficult because it's
expensive because you'll have to pay
2,000 duty tax and I can't giving you
tax advice because I'm not qualified and
because I don't even know your exact
situation but my guess would be that
you'll probably it'll probably cost more
money than you'll save by transferring
it all over so you're probably best to
just take the hit however make sure that
in future the properties that you buy
you buy them in a company also make sure
that your mortgages are small interest
payments are small in comparison to the
rent you probably pablor my estimation
my guess would be that the houses that
you own aren't that profitable they're
not great houses if you've been hit as
hard as you saying you might just have
to take it on the chin put the rents up
a little bit because of section 24 rents
are going up so maybe put your rents up
a little bit but I really don't think
it's wise to try and move it across into
a company because of
stamp duty and the fees and stuff that
you have to pay I hope it helps map X in
your opinion do you think their service
combination will be regulated at some
point and if so will there be
grandfather rights like a section for
like I think you mean article for we're
getting a lot of mixed up abbreviations
but that's all good see you at the crash
course on Friday boom I'll see you on
the crash course on Friday that's gonna
be incredible service combination will
it be regulated yes absolutely how do I
know because everything always becomes
regulated eventually and you've got to
make hay while the Sun shines I don't
know what exactly the legislation is
gonna be I don't know when it's going to
come in but what I'll say is just start
making money now and you can because it
always does whether they'll be
grandfather rights I don't know
no pond I always answer your questions a
little pump I hope you I hope you keep
watching these videos forever
is it possible to be a millionaire with
rent to rent as your primary strategy
yes
it is possible to be a millionaire we've
rent Tomatoes your primary strategy it
is possible to be a billionaire which is
a millionaire times a thousand we've
read to rent as your primary strategy
how can I say that because we work and
reduce our basically rent to rent
companies on a big scale and the guys
that started that company are both
billionaires through the rent to rent
company so it is absolutely possible I
tell you what I hope you enjoyed the
video drop your questions below but I'm
gonna I'm gonna I'm gonna recommend that
you guys watch an interview with myself
and good friend Ryan and Ryan is a
millionaire he does went to rents and
he's absolutely killing it a really
really really good guy I'd really
suggest you watch the interview I did
with Ryan but before you click elsewhere
drop your questions and comments below
smash that like button and once you've
done that check out my interview with
Ryan right here also if you want to
learn more about rent to rents and you
want to see me securing your rent to
read deal you can check that out right
here but whatever you do don't forget to
subscribe over here and if you want to
come to the crash course you can do that
right here see you next time
[Music]